former Attorney General Bill Barr is
here he is the author of one damn thing
after another Memoirs of an attorney
general General great to see you so
Lindsey Graham addressed this yesterday
he said this the solution to the cartel
problem is to declare them a foreign
terrorist organization and sick the U.S
military after them here's what he said
if there were an Isis or Al Qaeda cell
in Mexico that lobbed a rocket into
Texas we'd wipe them off the planet
they're doing that
times thousands again he's looking for
the foreign terrorist organization
designation but General Barr you say it
really doesn't matter what you call them
that's right the issue isn't what you
label them or designate them as the
issue is how you actually deal with them
and treat them but Lindsay's Bill a
proposal does not only designate them
but it also authorizes use of military
force but I do think you know just
designating them by himself and being
happy with that really wouldn't do very
much yeah the White House seems to be
pushing back on the notion as well this
is Kareem Jean-Pierre Mr Attorney
General on on the designation here's
where they stand listen
book designating these cartels as ftos
would not grant us any additional
authorities that we don't really have at
this time so the United States has
powerful sanctions authorities
specifically designated to combat
narcotics trafficking organizations so
you tell me what you think of that and
whether or not that is the case Mr
attorney general but
please clue our audience in for you know
they've been watching this story unfold
for not just years but decades obviously
with the cartels and in this moment you
are bringing a big light to this subject
because it's getting worse and worse and
it's killing so many Americans in this
country every day who are these cartel
members
well there are tens of thousands of of
members and uh there are some very large
cartels like the Sinaloa cartel but
they're also uh you know a number of
smaller cartels that essentially act as
subcontractors for the larger cartels
they control large parts of Mexico
they've completely intimidated the
government or neutralized the government
because they either bribe people because
they have oceans of money to do it uh or
they they terrorize them if a judge acts
against them if a police officer does
his job their families can be wiped out
and assassinated so it's a terrible
situation and this particular Mexican
government doesn't have the will to deal
with it I think they're content to
coexist
and allow these cartels to operate
against the United States and uh you
know we have to be realistic about the
fact that this is going to take direct
American involvement to deal with these
cartels they can be destroyed we
destroyed the cartels in Colombia when
when we uh did so in the early 1990s
right uh
this idea of going after them with the
U.S military or designated as foreign
terrorist organizations it's got some
supporters Lindsey Graham supports the
use of military force Dan Crenshaw
Sports the use of military force uh Ted
Cruz says thanks but I don't think we
need to be using the military to invade
our neighboring country Dan Crenshaw had
and also had an interesting point about
designating them as foreign terrorist
organizations he says that that would
trigger something that would make it
even worse listen to what he said
but you don't want to designate them as
that why because now you just made
millions of people in Mexico uh valid
Asylum Seekers so you just massively
increased our immigration problem at our
border if you call them terrorists so
speak to that idea if you say they're
terrorists who are living in Mexico and
these cartels are terrorist
organizations then you give people a
legal reason to come here to the United
States right I think just designate them
has Tupac one it doesn't give us that
much more power it gives us more power
to act directly against uh some of the
the leaders in the government for for
potentially uh colluding with the
cartels but uh Congressman Crenshaw is
right it allows the uh people to say
well if if they're terrorists then we
were legitimate refugees so we don't get
anything from it
the real question the really only
question is how do we deal directly with
these cartels now what we call them what
we do with them and there is no solution
other than using all the tools we have
trying to prosecute your way you know
indicting whoever these murderers were
recently that's not going to solve the
problem
uh and yeah what will
destroying the cartels by using every
tool we have intelligence tools military
Special Operations drones to collect
intelligence and to act against them yes
using the Mexicans that are willing to
help through vetted units that that we
know are safe and we can trust
information with uh and you can do it in
a very precise operation the the Specter
that this is invading Mexico is a red
herring no one's talking about rolling
armor down there and and uh taking over
the country we're able in operating
against groups like this such as Isis to
be much more precise and use limited uh
military resources to buttress the other
assets that we have but I think that's
what it will take we're talking a lot
about what we're doing about the cartels
in Mexico but we can put up the map to
show how they have infiltrated the
United States Mr attorney general and
and and the American people see this
happening they know this is happening
they know there's huge huge transfers of
money uh huge networks of money right
here in the United States I mean what
are we doing to to make sure that this
doesn't continue to grow and spread
well you're absolutely right not only do
they have these safe havens the fact
that they have safe havens in Mexico
means that they they're able to sit back
and do this and expand and they've taken
over our border they control our border
and now they're moving into different
areas of the country they're using gangs
that are up here uh you know to do some
of their dirty work I'm concerned that
they start using the same Terror tactics
up here that they do in Mexico there was
that family that was wiped out in in
California along with a little kid uh so
if there is no solution other than than
acting against the terrorists that's the
head of the snake
I want to ask you General Barr about the
hearing that just wrapped up in in
Congress and that's the first hearing of
the select committee into the
weaponization of government or not the
first one but hearing uh and there was
this exchange between Elise stefanik and
the FBI director over the FBI's
involvement with Twitter over the 100
Biden laptop story listen here
were you aware that the FBI Personnel
were in contact with Twitter regarding
the hunter Biden laptop story
I I don't believe FBI Personnel were in
contact with with Twitter about the 100
laptop story specifically I think there
were people in contact with Twitter
about Russian disinformation efforts
were you aware that the FBI had Hunter
Biden's laptop since December of 2019
I can't speak to exactly when we had a
laptop available hey stonewalling
director Ray the American people deserve
answers and this is unacceptable so
there's this issue Gerald bar about
plausible deniability here that the FBI
might not have specifically mentioned
Hunter Biden or the laptop but it primed
the pump the pump to the degree that
even Mark Zuckerberg the head of
Facebook said when the 100 byte laptop
story came around they said at Facebook
ah this is what the FBI is talking about
I'm a little dubious about that you know
I was there at the time I was the
attorney general and there was a lot of
pressure on the uh FBI to make sure
there was no foreign interference in the
election and uh as far as I was aware
they were giving General briefings uh to
different groups to say you know be on
the guard for for uh foreign activity
like the Bots that were used uh in 2016.
and uh
I I don't know I think we have to look
exactly what those briefings were and
what was being said to those companies
uh because if they were saying you know
things like the hunter laptop or getting
too particular about the kinds of things
they were looking for that would have
crossed the line in my opinion now uh
did Zuckerberg you know it was Facebook
really you know just being good citizens
here and doing what the FBI said my
guess is like every other company they
received General briefings and then when
they were caught doing what they did
uh they are hiding behind the general
breed oh we thought that that's you know
we were just responding to this General
briefing but this is going to be very
fact specific I think we have to find
out more exactly these are really
serious allegations I mean this is the
weaponization of the federal government
and it doesn't look like things are
turning around anytime soon I'm sorry to
change it the whole idea that the
government should be encouraging
companies to take out stuff that's false
is Israel that's a violation of the
First Amendment okay the first amendment
actually protects protects false speech
and uh for the idea that the government
goes and encourages companies to exclude
that stuff to me is a direct violation
of the First Amendment and I'd like to
see some litigation to enjoin the
government from that kind of stuff in
the future that's misconduct uh and I
think we have to address these companies
through Section 230 reform of feeling
that they it's one thing to take
something away if it's illegal
like pornography or something that
actually violates the law but just
because you think something is wrong
doesn't give you the right to take it
down but as Michael schellenberger who
was testifying this morning said he
believes that's where the so-called
censorship industrial complex is you
don't have to be a threat you just have
to be wrong right in their eyes because
some of the stuff that was wrong in
their eyes turned out to be right but
most of the important stuff turned out
to be right and that just eviscerates
the First Amendment
General Barr always great to spend time
with you thank you so much for being
with us thank you thank you so much
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ansley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis